- A few months ago I got an email
from a company called Sparkmate.
They build prototypes.
If you, or your company, has an idea
for a thing and the money to make it,
they will build that thing for you.
They said to me, "Tom, we've got a bit
of spare time and want some publicity,
"do you have anything weird
that you want built?"
So I looked through the long list
of impractical projects
that are on my ideas board, and
I realized that I could answer a question
that I've had since I was very young.
When I was a kid I watched a show called
Captain Scarlet and the Mysterons.
It was a tale of good versus evil,
the heroic agents of Spectrum
fighting against the Mysterons from Mars.
It was made with puppets,
the hero character was indestructible,
which say brave narrative choice,
and most people remember
one thing about it:
the weird decision to do
big scene transitions like this.
[loud drumbeats, timed with video cuts]
Captain Scarlet was made in the '60s,
rerun in the '90s,
and kids like the young version of me
loved it.
It turns out decades old shows
are still interesting
when you only have four TV channels
and no internet.
Rewatching it as an adult for this video?
First, it's now in HD,
so you can see the puppet strings,
and it is brutally violent
for a kid's show.
In the first episode there's blood,
death by gunshot,
and an alien replicant blowing himself up,
and the production didn't
shy away from that
by cutting to a reaction shot
of other characters.
The special effects team literally put
explosives inside a puppet and blew it up.
Wholesome family kids' entertainment there.
And the plots often make no sense.
I try to summarize the alien plan from
that first episode for this script,
and I just gave up.
It makes no sense and it keeps changing.
No one in the entire episode,
human or alien, acts in any rational way.
It's all just an excuse for cool
action scenes and explosions.
And as a kid,
I didn't notice any of the plot holes,
because there were cool action scenes
and explosions.
Plus the futuristic vehicles.
The most famous of
which was the Spectrum Pursuit Vehicle,
the SPV.
According to the lore of the
show it weighs eight tons,
but also somehow floats.
Its top speed is 200 miles an hour,
and it comes equipped with
rocket cannons, ejector seats,
and a jet pack.
Almost every episode,
a Spectrum agent would arrive at
some apparently normal location,
and an SPV would be revealed
in an overdramatic way.
The team at Sparkmate
have not made me an SPV.
I'd love to have one,
but unfortunately this is reality,
but there's one other bizarre feature of
this thing
that always stuck with me as a kid.
And it's introduced in that first episode
by a couple of lines of dialogue
that show just how far voice acting in kid
shows has improved since the '60s.
- I see you have expert ratings on SPVs.
[monotone] It must be tricky facing
backwards and driving by TV monitor.
- Ah, you get used to it.
- You drive the SPV facing
backwards using a screen.
In the show, the explanation
for that is that it's safer.
If you're in a crash you stand a better
chance of survival if you're facing backwards.
That's true.
There are real world studies
that show that,
but from a production perspective,
why would you do that?
It's not required for the plot.
It just looks confusing to have
the background going the wrong way
and surely the characters
would get motion sick
and confused by how everything's turning.
It's such a weird design choice.
It even shows up on the toy versions.
If you open the doors here,
the little action figures
are facing backwards.
Even as a kid, I thought,
surely, that's not a good idea.
So Sparkmate have made me a go-kart
that's driven backwards using a screen,
and that's literally all I know.
I gave them that brief,
showed them Captain Scarlet episodes.
They said, "That sounds fun,"
and now I'm sitting in their office
in an industrial park
on the outskirts of Paris
about to see the results
for the first time,
so I can answer the question I've had
since I was a kid.
You can't actually drive facing backwards.
Right?
[loud drumbeats matching cuts]
Oh, wow.
- Hope you like it!
- This is the SPV, man!
- That's amazing.
So you have a whole television
monitor there for all the details.
Is that a... is that a game controller?
-Yes, it is.
- Actually the first test that we did
was with this steering wheel and pedal,
and we decided to switch from
a steering wheel to an Xbox game pad.
Why?
Because the challenge for us
was to create a gamified experience
of driving a vehicle,
just like in a video game somehow.
- And this camera...
- Is what you're seeing in the front.
We even implemented some--
[honks horn]
- That is annoyingly loud and
I love it.
I've got to remember
the cart is facing this way.
Yes, let's take it out and see...
This feels way more dangerous
all of a sudden!
I also appreciate that this has
full harness seat belts.
I thought we were going to make
a tiny little thing
that I'd sit on
and it would go at low speed.
What's the top speed on this?
- In this area, we reached a 40km/h,
but with a higher distance, wider field,
we could reach 50-something, for sure.
- Wait. What's this for?
- This is a handbrake, emergency brake,
because sometimes things can happen!
For example, if we lose control,
or we just lose the controller.
Brake, and that would be fine.
- So, low-speed test in the car park?
- Yes, that's fine.
- High-speed test on the track later.
- Yes, go for that.
- Let's do it.
- We thought about different positions,
we even thought of driving
laid at the bottom of the cart,
that was obviously a dangerous position,
so we went back to
a backward seated position.
I would say it's just after some tests
with our team trying
what's the most comfortable...
I would say we tried and we ended up here
in this average position.
- There we go. Avoid...
no, that's going for some cars.
I'm 100% aiming for some cars.
Let's not do that.
I'm aiming for the trucks
which are this way, here we go.
- It's a bit confusing
at the beginning.
-Oh, it's really confusing,
I don't like this!
-Try to be a bit slower
at the beginning,
because that's a bit messing
with your mind at first.
- Agreed! It really is.
- We actually used a
very powerful motor,
a powerful servo motor
to control the direction system.
We went through a lot of iterations and
trials and error to configure the system.
Also on the mechanical part,
how do we install it,
how do we control it
so that it's smooth?
That was a tricky part, I would say,
but once we had the propulsion system,
the direction system,
then we were good to go to have fun.
- All right, let's go down the road.
I got-- oh, that's too fast.
That's way too fast.
I nearly went the wrong way.
I need to steer away from the van.
I nearly steered into the van.
Got to remember the monitor--
- Keep your focus on the monitor.
- Whoa, that was a drain,
I went straight over it!
Keep your focus on the monitor,
the monitor is all that counts.
The minute I start thinking about
the real world outside the monitor,
my brain misfires, I get left and right-
oh, that was a speed bump-
I get left from right mixed up.
- You're driving pretty well.
I'm very impressed.
- Let's bring it to a stop just here.
It's possible, but for someone who hasn't
played video games in 15, 20 years,
I can do a lap around here,
it's just confusing to get used to it.
It's just confusing that
the world is going one way,
but I have to focus everything
on the screen.
- The visualization part,
we did a lot of iterations,
we did a lot of tests, a lot of coding,
and as you can imagine,
the main problem was latency.
We tried different things,
but we always had to fight latency.
We thought about drones, VR,
we ended up, I think the version that
we have right now is using WebRTC,
from a web browser communicating
through sockets to Unreal Engine.
That's the most, I would say,
advanced we went on the VR part.
- I asked the team for a steering wheel
and we have a hastily jerry-rigged
steering wheel here,
because it's just
a different type of controller.
I've spent way more time with one of
these than I have with a game controller.
You all ready?
All right, let's see how this...
Oh, that's nicer. Here we go. That's it.
Yep, okay, focus on screen. Anyone coming?
No one coming.
We turn left out of here.
Slowly here, slow. That's good.
You've got the sensitivity right now.
That's it. Here we go. A bit of speed.
- Focus on the screen.
- Oh!
- What I did there was I turned right
when I should've turned left.
You're okay?
-Wow! We're just fine, man.
We just avoided this steel thing.
- The good news is that the car works
and it goes at speed.
-What happened? You were not
focused on the screen, no?
- I was very focused on the screen,
and all I needed to do was turn left,
and my brain turned right.
Wow, that's confusing.
Well, I hate to say
"let's go to the track" on that,
but we should probably go to the track,
because I don't like the fact
that we're doing this around cars now.
I've got lead foot.
I was so confident.
- Fortunately, nothing bad happened.
- You built a strong kart there.
- We just bumped,
we got scared, and that's it.
That's life.
- You built a strong kart, we're fine.
Let's go to the track.
[loud drumbeats, matching cuts]
Power on, lights on,
little bit of acceleration.
There we go.
That is twitchy. We're fine.
Concentrate on the screen,
Tom, concentrate on the screen.
Make it around the track.
There we go, there we go.
Good.
Little bit of straight here,
line it up there.
This is working.
That's a little bit off course.
We're okay, we're good.
Now we're on the straight.
Floor it, let's see
what this thing can do.
Whoa! Okay.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Brake.
Yes, and right around here.
Brake into the corner.
Wow, that's a strong left turn.
That was a strong left turn,
but I went the right way.
The correct way.
I didn't go the right way,
I went the correct way.
Nearly.
I can't believe I'm saying this,
but it works!
I was expecting to get motion sick.
I was expecting to fall over.
I was expecting it to be like
"this old puppet show was terrible".
Yes, you can absolutely drive like that.
My problems were sight lines
and not being used to the controls,
and this being a quickly jerry-rigged wheel.
- Are you saying that
cars should be like this?
- I'm not saying it's an
improvement on driving forwards,
but if I'd crashed, I would've been safer!
[laughs]
It works. Thank you, folks.
We've answered a question
I had for 25 years!
Thank you.